(hypnotic music)
- [Narrator] This is
Pierre, a hooded vulture.
Native to Sub-Saharan Africa,
hooded vultures are critically endangered.
They are the smallest of African vultures,
only slightly larger than a crow.
They are scavengers.
And because of their small size,
they end up waiting by carcasses
and eating the scraps left
behind by bigger birds.
Adults have white
feathers behind the neck,
which forms a hood over its head.
They live in forest
clearings where it rains,
coastal marshes, and lagoons.
Hooded vultures are unafraid of humans
and can be found in villages and towns,
often referred to as garbage
collectors by locals.
Due to a combination
of hunting, poisoning,
and habitat degradation, their population
over the last three generations
has declined over 80%.
This is the hooded vulture.